[Musik]
die schweiz ist ein land der erfinder
eines der erfolgreichsten weltweit vor
dem einfallsreichtum der erfinder ist
nichts sicher
sie sind angetrieben von neuen denken
ans bisher unbedachte und sie vergessen
dabei manchmal wichtiger als richtig ein
erfinder des toni will ihre ideen sind
für die welt von morgen
sie leben den traum vom großen
durchbruch und greifen dafür nach den
sternen
[Musik]
der finder wollen die welt verbessern
unseren alltag erleichtern und natürlich
erfolgreich sein
ihre vorhaben beginnen meist naiv ihr
weg ist steinig und nur wenige schaffen
es
[Musik]
wer in die luft gehen will muss auf dem
boden bleiben
das ist ein wichtiger leitsatz von
erfinder andreas reinhardt dem
leibhaftigen daniel düsentrieb reinhardt
und sein team hier mit drei die
physikerin seraina klaus arbeiten an
einem kühnen projekt es heißt sky lift
und soll nichts weniger als den
eiffelturm in den schatten stellen
der ski lift ist ein schwebender
ballonen auf eineinhalb kilometer höhe
darauf integriert ist eine
aussichtsplattform die man per aufzug
erreicht quasi ein lift in den himmel
das teil ist dieses symbol eigentlich
führen neue dimensionen
es ist bis wo man welche boot das er von
menschen gebautes werk dieser fall
kilometern fährt extrem liegt auf der
anderen seite ist es so weit
der reflektor mannschaft sie haben sich
frankreich forschung vorstellen
dasselbe symbol sie vom mut verkehr haid
und vor sollen die tat vor allem von der
kombination von flash
die reise im ski lift beginnt unter
wasser in einem aquarium
der passagier steigt in eine gondel in
der form eines fisches entschwindet dem
wasser und ist nach nur 90 sekunden
fahrt oben angelangt wie sie an
stationen stationen mit
unterschiedlichen zahlen und spezielle
der klinischen phase schädlich kopie von
monde auf mich zählt
der ballon ist über seile mit einer
bodenstation verbunden und dreht sich im
wind wie ein vor anker liegendes schiff
[Musik]
geradezu poetisch wird es in der nacht
denn der skylifter erscheint in einem
umkreis von zwölf kilometern
hinsichtlich helligkeit und größe wie
ein zweiter mond
seit fast 20 jahren tüftelt reinhardt an
diesem visionären und auch etwas
utopischen projekt das sind die ersten
projektskizzen wie kommt er eigentlich
auf seine ideen
ihr fahrerisches standard rezept geht
die gene wie plätze stand können
und je mehr als man anfing approbierte
signalisiere wir sogar also wieder
besser hätte man versuche nicht finde
das eigentlich bei der druck nimmt der
leser zurück und das ganze wird teuer
geschätzte 400 millionen euro soll das
himmlische abenteuer verschlingen
gibt die rohstoffe hat eine geschätzte
400 millionen euro das beinhaltet ganz
entwicklung und frauen die ganze
zertifiziert vom beteiligt wo er schätze
dass gegen sie ingenieurin ist natürlich
noch mal nach hinten einem sitz von gott
her aber natürlich hof oder von den
entscheidungs werk geht's eigentlich nur
sehr wenig nation aber so ein bisschen
frei kommt dass sie autokratisch
organist land wo ich glaube nicht dass
man das projekt bringt in vielen von
reinhardts erfindungen steckt der traum
vom fliegen zum beispiel der aufblasbare
stachelrochen der stingray mit dem er
mitte der 90er jahre aufmerksamkeit
erregte
zum sinn dieses liedes sagte er damals
wir haben sehr stark von die lega fragen
unter anderen der fähigkeit der fantasie
areal ist also wo man selbst schlagen
ich geben wenn man es braucht
die fliegen der luftmatratze wie der
stingray auch schon neckisch genannt
wurde ist heute ein museumsstück
das selbst leegebruch man denkt das
gehört eben zum tüftler und das hat bis
in anderen verlauf nehmen das ist glaub
es ist also herr und realistischer
pousadas jedes projekt geht so vor deren
die er gerade aus muss ein anderer hätte
also im stingray so sexy dass mir das
ist mutig serbe vor acht neue patente
aufkauft feindlicher wasser zum beispiel
der ersetzen wirklichkeit wollen diese
mit luftdruck regulierbaren sitzpolster
kommen heute in passagierjets zum
einsatz sparen dort gewicht und kosten
mit solchen und vielen anderen
auftragsarbeiten für die industrie
verdiente reinhard gutes geld geld das
er unter anderem in die entwicklung des
kliffs investierte die schwebende
aussichtsplattform soll ein
technologieträger werden potenzielle
auftraggeber hat er schon an der angel
aber dazu später
das geistige eigentum des sky lift
verwaltet josef färber patentanwalt
erfinder coach physiker er hat schon
viele erfindungen gesehen aber auf ein
projekt wie den sky lift trifft auch er
nicht alle tage
ich brauche die james crowley fleisch
und doch dass ich fünf technische
aufgabe hinter uns gegrüßt war dafür das
konzept zu realisieren sei das wird
jetzt am laufenden band noch gemacht und
noch gebaut das glaube ich nicht
das sind wirklich das ganz einzelnen
muss über eine realität und das war
schon ein bombenerfolg neben reinhard
betreut felber patente von camus und
internationalen firmen in ihm brennt ein
feuer für die welt der erfindungen oder
vermeintliche ski verreckt
aber immerhin es sind immer neue sachen
und war die branche höhere und sind
natürlich furchtbar
[Musik]
die erfinder sind nicht nur spannende
menschen sie sind auch wichtig und
wertvoll für die schweiz forscht
technische betrieb das ein pionier xi
wohl es dank der großartigen selber
schreibt nicht nur patentanträge
manchmal gibt er erfindern auch tipps
auf ihrem steinigen weg wie diesem
tüftler der auf ein elektrovelo setzt
und das ist er robert mayer er hat den
legendären velo solex neu interpretiert
[Musik]
das ist der prototyp ein elektrovelo mit
vorderradantrieb vorne elektro hinten
mountainbike der rote design schnabel
ist das batteriefach meyer tüftelt seit
jahren an dieser wie er es nennt
revolution des elektro velos
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm gar nehme ich sondern wir
sind traktoren sven dennoch erzielt mit
seinem bausatz kann er jedes normale
velo in ein e bike verwandeln ich habe
mir eine bike bringe und dichter denn
das montieren oder dich und das stelle
wie mir und selber montieren bike week
mit der leitung natürlich die batterie
steckte zwischen den lenker in eine
verschalung den motor im vorderrad
kaufte ein
jetzt machen wir es kurz ähnliche
bausätze gibt es zwar schon aber dieser
sei einzigartig meint der tüftler
nicht einmal halb stimmt für monteure
normale bausatz wie petra drewer sie
können über die bei und überall kaufen
kostet zwar weniger aber sie ein minimum
impact on air und den überraschenden
kabel und alles themen durch alles schön
kompakt und vorderradantrieb ist unter
ebikes wenig verbreitet spezialisten
raten eher davon ab meyers e bike wurde
in fachkreisen auch schon mal als
gefährlich eingestuft alles unsinn
meinte erfinder und ich glaube dass mal
ein mal eines park fahrer sind wir jetzt
das sofa dem ich spreche dass es ideal
toni kurz und des sicheres fahrzeug und
den glauben wie jetzt blumen
davon ist auch patentanwalt selber
überzeugt trotz des gegenwindes aus der
fachwelt einen produzenten für den truck
haben sie aber bislang nicht gefunden
[Musik]
wir schauen wir wieder ganz nah
wenn man so ein findiger technisches
problem größter braucht meistens erzeugt
ihr wenig wie es immer aktiviert wie
immer so anbringung das verkaufen gehört
nicht zu meiner stärken er die seien
schon lieber mal das nächste modell
es soll ein allradantrieb werden
[Musik]
denkt man ja ja das geld was jetzt
ohrringe und sondern der weg ist dass
sie mich dann voll auf dem drin und die
sich wirklich hinter dieser gelegenheit
mit dem geld die sind weniger die
effekte sind ableitung blendet die für
den erst wenn neben den metallisch
sturheit ja also wenn das fahrzeug
produzieren das von zwei prototypen
machen denn standhalten
[Musik]
wen kommt ströher und erfinder der tv
stuhr ist niemandsland der noch nie
gemacht und das riesen herausforderung
den wünschen nach bestätigung habe
muss einfach wahnsinnig idealismus als
freier autor und die gewinnzone macht
eigentlich alles seine technisch
vorstellen maschinen und alles wenn im
film
ich halte ja ein helikopter entwickelt
das wäre für milch kreis problem form
auch vom schuljahr erreicht das system
jetzt genau ich wusste genau wie es
müsste sie dass die augen
helikopterflüge der mystiker kompliziert
die ingenieure bereich gemacht dass das
ist die natur das haupt füße
patentanwalt josef färber weiß aus
erfahrung die zeiten für ein mann
erfinder sind heute schwieriger als
früher
das neunzehnte und zwanzigster
jahrhundert waren in der schweiz die
goldenen pionier und erfinder zeiten
lebensmittel inspirierten die erfinder
damals zum beispiel die herstellung von
schokolade das armee taschenmesser
stammt aus dieser zeit sowie die
erfindungen des straßentheaters von
ernst purine die
im entscheid verdankt diesen selbstlosen
gelehrten zwei wichtige erfindungen
die sauerstoffmaske herten ist den
fliegern erlaubt in große höhen
vorzudringen und den feuerwehrleiten der
gefahr des erstickens im bauch zu
trotzen und 22 seine idee den er zur
bekämpfung des straßenstaub es zu
benutzen
der durch das aufkommen des autors zur
wirklichen klar geworden war dass diese
ihre tanks andere entwickelten in dieser
epoche dampfturbinen oder
elektrifizierten die eisenbahn
[Musik]
für erfinder und pioniere herrschten
damals ideale rahmenbedingungen
freihandel protestantische arbeitsmoral
wenig staatliche regulierung und unter
hochschulen
[Musik]
das ist eine riesige aufbruchstimmung
ich seh oder drei erfindet die andere
jagt oder ein unglaublicher
fortschrittsglaube kann dank eines
unserer natur ist ganz weit oben oder
und immer mehr und blüht es dort nur zu
holen und und eigenschaft noch dran oder
wodka und auch geistig ist ehrgeizig er
sich außer frage ich sie und das gesetz
und reglementieren gegangen weil wir
eine richtig kreativ schaffe aber nicht
jede erfolgreiche erfindung hat ihren
erfinder auch reich gemacht zum beispiel
per casting
er legte 1938 den grundstein für den
welterfolg des ar all dies gestern
suchte eigentlich nach haft stoffen für
die dritten zähne und fand dabei ein
verfahren das später die herstellung des
all dies ermöglichte das patent
verkaufte er an ciba geigy zu einem
spottpreis
ein ähnliches schicksal ereilte georges
de mestral den erfinder des klett
verschlusses seine erfindung ist zwar
auch ein welterfolg geworden
raich hat sie ihn aber nicht gemacht den
kommerziellen erfolg ernten seine
nachahmer
nach ablauf des patentschutzes der
patentschutz sich das da wollen die
macht und im prinzip vorwärtsbringen
technologisch und jaffé
vorstandsvertrags dass da auch selber
küste zieht dann können die früchte
exklusiv 120 maximal braucht es aus
brand die meisten erfindungen und
patente kommen aus großen firmen von
erfinder teams ist die zeit der einzel
erfinder abgelaufen
sie verweist auf in der woche steht für
mich die entscheidende idee und meistens
braucht die stimmen als ein harmloser
die andere höfe dennoch ruhe und und
verrechnung darsteller und
ausführungsfehler unter loose schaffe
aber die entscheidende idee die ich auf
familie eignet uns ein user
aus einem herren stammt auch die idee zu
dieser etwas andersartigen windturbine
die hier per helikopter eingeflogen
kommt
es ist nummer 40 die in betrieb genommen
wird die anderen sind über die ganze
welt verteilt erfunden hat die
windturbine roman bühler
die idee dazu hatte er vor fünf jahren
haben eine sägeblätter wofür vor allem
gekauft war ein wahnsinnig herzblut am 4
am wochenende scharfe den flügel und
schlicht für unmöglich macht die zimbra
firma mittag stellte und mit der größten
verantwortung und es ist einfach einen
riesigen unterschiedlichen möglichen
grünen roman bühlers faszination für den
wind für das fliegen geht bis in seine
kindheit zurück das kühl flügen aber
verdient ich natürlich sehr intensiv im
meer verankert deshalb früheren
modellbau angefangene zehn jahren ja
anfangen säge fluege.de motor flüge
kunstflug sowieso die extremform flüge
hinter mir
die aerodynamik das ganze zu verstehen
und so ist schon so etwas wie ein dort
um sachen und so hat es 2008 angefangen
mit einem kleinen modell windrad auf
einem lastwagen als ersatz für den
teuren windkanal die erfindung steckte
damals noch in den kinderschuhen
davon unabhängig sind der clou an seiner
windturbine sind die verstellbaren
flügel die sich immer optimal in den
wind stellen und so bis zu 30 prozent
mehr leistung bringen sollen
im jahr 2009 nach einem jahr tüfteln und
entwickeln steckte bühler seine ganzen
ersparnisse in den bau des ersten
prototypen freunde und sein bruder
daniel halfen mit
das design seiner windturbine gefiel
bühler wurde von bestellungen überrannt
er gründete eine firma der erfinder war
plötzlich auch unternehmer dabei hatte
er noch gar nicht anders verkaufen
gedacht nachdem doch gar nicht verkauft
setzt sich gedanken was in division
überholen also eigentlich immer vor
darauf hinter wo mit geld film ortet
eine klassische erfinder schwäche um die
finanzen kümmerten sich andere dumas
windturbine nahm so richtig fahrt auf
die gewesen dalí rundum inklusive bar
überrascht sie wo wir schnell dass der
für schick gegangen ist wie viel
interesse gestoßen sind
die leichten karbon flügel sind das
herzstück der anlage bei diesen tests
vor drei jahren brachen sie erst unter
extremen überbelastungen 14 anlagen
waren im jahr 2010 in betrieb
das windrad stand damals gut im wind
doch dann der rückschlag bei dieser
anlage brachen die flügel der höhenflug
des windrads wurde jäh gestoppt der
erfinder stand plötzlich am abgrund
flügel der riese bruch hin dass ich die
sache spaß gemacht hat aufgrund von dem
bruch anlagen die stillgelegte und ali
flügelwechsel warum zwei millionen
gekostet und ist fasst nick bach und die
andern das finanzieren
während liebhaber es glaubt ist golf
endlich finanzierung zu machen und was
eigentlich immer so wie trainer braucht
alle flügel im jahr zu setzen da sie
nicht wenig century seehofer noch wieder
gesund der flügel aber alle idee aber
auf
alle meine jungs wechsel ein gericht hat
die ursachen geklärt
die schuld liegt bei seinem ehemaligen
flügel produzenten
märz 2012 trotz der fast pleite stand
der erfinder wieder auf und baute mit
hilfe starker schweizer industrie
partner eine doppelt so große
windturbine sie soll energie für 20
einfamilienhäuser liefern das scheitern
hat den erfinder auch stark gemacht
glück und interessant immer wieder dass
gold treffer
so wäre ja eine zu finden für mich auf
internet einfach glück sondern auch in
dänisch chemie und prozess schritt für
schritt neu wirksames für heute steht
wieder mit seiner erfindung an einem
wendepunkt 2014 erwartet der schwarze
zahlen
doch eigentlich ist er in gedanken schon
woanders höre mich ganz klar ich bitte
daher wohl garage blättern gibt es macht
wenn der punkt erreicht wird wo setzt
dich ist zeigen die arbeit gemacht
was ist ihr egal wenn du zum optimieren
und viel viel verreisen nur ums geld und
weniger der fall müsse daher auch also
her und macht aber was ist das energie
und wasser rolle zurück zu andreas
reinhardt dem anderen herren der lüfte
dem mann der einen lift in den himmel
bauen will
ein mammutprojekt mit vielen unbekannten
der respekt vor seiner türe und
verrückte projekt das ist ja nett
belastet sondern ist eine vordergrund
rohstoff was braucht ohne sonstige
herausforderung ein starkes neues lothar
der bruch mit einem projekt muss man
verschiedenes wechsel auf bemustert city
haben dank eines neuen gemacht hätten
wir ihn aber unbekannt ist und bei dir
hier unsicherheit und dienst vorsieht
die spannung
der global tätige adrenalin bereich
linie was altes fahrrad ermöglichen
die sicherheit ist beim sky lift ein
entscheidender aspekt wind ist zum
beispiel ein heikler punkt bei moderaten
preisen dreht sich das skyloft mit dem
wind bei strom ist vorgesehen dass der
ganze ballon innerhalb von fünf minuten
herein geholt wird
aus dieser einigung sei möglich ich
denke dass ich aus dem fisch probieren
wir es erst ab sonntag glaube es könnte
terroristische jährige konnte als
mancher denkt und verbraucht je variante
wo sehr unwahrscheinlich
mit einem 1 zu 10 modell hat reinhard
wichtige komponenten des kf schon
getestet
13 millionen franken hat er in dieses
projekt gesteckt aus der eigenen tasche
das war alles nett dass er wenn wir das
geld müsste man da oben ist die
abschreibung der software in der cloud
also sehr hoch vor der wirtschaft ein
positives berichten klasse und ich
glaube daran dass man
[Musik]
das können der buchstaben das projekt
investiert welche thema optionen oder
andere spannende brücke eines dieser
projekte hat reinhard schon in angriff
genommen bei schweizer jugend forscht in
bern coacht und fördert er die nachwuchs
erfinder dan tüfteln soll früh gelernt
sein
in kassel az b geschafft dienen muss
möglichst oft wurzeln und show aus
dürfte die forscherin wir mit dem
legeren die meckern auf mit 460 auf
knopfdruck kann auch unsere jetzige zu
finden werde mit 220 das braucht
geschichte was sie jetzt wissen wie sie
das mich entweder selber kennt und
deswegen investiere vorzieht junge
potenzial des vom brand aber auch diese
junge erfinder wollen nichts weniger als
einen vogel nachbauen
die idee dahinter sei notorisch
revolutioniert sozusagen bis neues zu
entwickeln
ich darf wieder bis zu bringen also
vertrauen klinik am künstlichen vogel
haben sich schon einige die zähne
ausgebissen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass auch die
jungen tüftler daran scheitern ist groß
ich denke was wiederum bei den berufen
ist dass sie an lockeren umgang mit dem
schütteren dass du das machen die
medizinische aufgaben oder vielleicht
sogar ins geschäft gekommen
in den usa ist das nicht was traum aber
ihnen als person verknüpft hier bestand
markt wird aus der schweiz dass man die
lockerheit erholt hat als ein formel ist
hier das mit dir
neben ihren mut zum risiko bereits auch
der velo tüftler
denn die konkurrenz bei den e-bikes ist
riesig war sehr fehlen der spielt das
eco wahnsinnig aber wäre nicht so geil
dass diego im hauptfeld schlecht ich um
ein grad um grad und graf will keine
hilfe der tüftler lebt im zürcher
langstrassenquartier zusammen mit seiner
senegalesischen frau früher war eine
große nummer in der designszene er
machte gürtel für die stars keith
richards joan collins von denver clan
kauften bei ihm ein
für den star designer für gürtel und den
rückstand schnell dass sich für die
prominenz aus aller welt ist eine der
ersten überhaupt über mich ich glaube
das ist ein vip klub von der wolke
sieben doch dann vor ein paar jahren
stagnierte der gürtel verkauf meyer
geriet in eine abwärtsspirale
ja ich habe sechs konkurs macht ja als
privatkonkurs will seifert nämlich gar
nicht jede tage briefen und die böse
telefon und das ist natürlich schon
fertig macht mit dem elektrovelo will er
nun einen neuanfang machen ja sich als
mittel zum die schuldenmacherei erstes
mal ab lottozahlen uns zweite die ich
einfach dass mir auch dass sie kann wie
die idee wollenhaupt fan wollte immer
nur um mich wählt also ich gehe raus
bringen ist für mich als riese nach
darüber bis entwerfen soll das wird den
elf bisher
mut zum risiko zeigten auch viele
schweizer erfinder im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert einige ihrer ideen schafften
den durchbruch
wie zum beispiel der küchenmixer der
sparschäler oder die wäschespinne steht
jeder erfinder ist in geistige der
pioniere nimmt immer bis geistig vorweg
und der pionier in form einer erfinder
und andere ist natürlich eine wohnung
kostet und know how das produzieren und
telematics führen oder das ist noch
einige luft
daran scheitert er zum beispiel nicht
los wird
er baute 1981 den weltweit ersten
arbeitsplatz rechner mit maus die
vermarktung gelang jedoch nicht eine
gesellschaftliche revolution hingegen
löste die erfindung des internets am
cern in genf aus und zu den
wirtschaftlich erfolgreichsten
erfindungen zählt sicherlich der kaffee
aus der kapsel
das braune gold im alu kleid generiert
heute umsätze in milliardenhöhe und
mache die schweiz zum kaffee land von
der erfindung bis zum kommerziellen
erfolg vergingen über zwei jahrzehnte
und er hat den kapsel café erfunden eric
favre espresso ist mein kind ich habe es
kreiert und erfunden
wenn ich heute in eine nespresso
boutique gehe und die kleine kapsel in
der ecke sehe und sie sieht mich an dann
sage ich zu mir schau was wir gemeinsam
geschafft haben es ist eine typische
vater kind beziehung der westschweizer
fahrer war als junger ingenieur
fasziniert vom geheimnis der
kaffeezubereitung inspiriert hat ihn
seine frau eine italienerin
ich denke er wollte mir beweisen dass er
wirklich guten kaffee machen kann
es war ihr ernst er sagte
schau her meine kleine italienerin ich
werde ja zeigen wie man guten kaffee
macht
[Musik]
rückblende 1975 favre hat frisch bei
nestlé angeheuert kaffee gehört nicht zu
seinen aufgaben
[Musik]
favre geht mit seiner frau auf reisen
ziel ist italien das mekka des espresso
cafés
[Musik]
in rom besucht das paar unzählige
kaffeebars
im café san akio findet fahrer den
meister der espresso zubereitung der
barista wirbelt den hebeln der
espressomaschine wie ein künstler
während der kaffee heraus tropfte
mission die nächste tasse und machte
weiter er war ein meister im café machen
wie ein großer tisch
[Musik]
favre rätselt liegt es an der acht der
zubereitung an der maschine vielleicht
oder an der kaffeesorte es war ein sehr
ruhiger moment ich war in bad hörte
klassische musik und dann plötzlich kam
der einfall du begreifst plötzlich alles
und sagst dir
wieso habe ich so lange dafür gebraucht
das geheimnis war die richtige menge
luft im café nächsten tag bin ich sofort
ins labor von nestlé gegangen mein
techniker war gut in boston
er nahm einen filter von einer alten
kaffeemaschine füllte ihn mit kaffee gab
heißes wasser und druckluft dazu
und das ist die nachgebaute
versuchsanordnung von 1976 so sei die
allererste nespresso maschine der welt
aus ein perfekter café bremer aber
wirklich perfekt nachher brauchte ich
etwa eine woche um die technik zu
verfeinern um das genaue gleichgewicht
zwischen den druck eine luft wasser und
kaffee zu finden
von dem moment an wusste ich die
erfüllung wahr gemacht
ich sagte es niemandem aber auch dem
mechaniker gesagt sage es niemand danach
versuchte ich das ganze hier in eine
kapsel zu bringen
favre tüftelt an der form der kapsel
nach unzähligen versuchen hat er die
richtige gefunden
1976 patentierte er seine idee
zwei jahre später präsentiert er seine
erfindung der generaldirektion in einer
zeit wo alle nur von nescafé sprechen
aus angst der kapsel café könnte die
geldmaschine nescafé konkurrenzieren
wird farbe abgesagt ich musste
versprechen nie mehr an dem kapsel
projekt weiterzuarbeiten
das habe ich zwar versprochen aber nicht
getan
1983 sieben jahre nach der erfindung
noch ziert fahre den kapsel café in
japan ein totaler misserfolg nach
weiteren rückschlägen entschließt er
sich nestlé zu verlassen
zuvor will er aber noch dem konzern chef
helmut maucher seine meinung sagen
ich habe herrn maucher gesagt dass ich
finde
nestlé sei stark um ein bestehendes
produkt zu vermarkten
sogar eine der besten firmen weltweit
nestlé sa so stark um ein produkt zu
verbessern
aber andersherum sein nestlé sehr
schlecht bei der erfindung und
lancierung neuer produkte und das die
letzte wirkliche erfindung der nescafé
war die konzernleitung unter maucher
lenkt ein
er überzeugt fahre zu bleiben gibt
grünes licht für das projekt und macht
ihn 1986 zum ersten von nespresso hinter
dem logo steckt eine besondere
geschichte
für mich war nespresso gar nicht
maskulin sondern feminin
warum sagst du das nicht gleich sagte
der logo designer und ruft seine
assistentin und sagte ihr sie solle ihre
schuhe ausziehen
der kapsel kaffee kommt anfangs nicht
auf touren
er geht sogar selbst von tür zu tür und
versucht das produkt unter die leute zu
bringen
ein problem wird zum beispiel dass der
kaffee den kapseln nicht drauf es gab
keinen kaffee geruch ein amerikanischer
verkäufer sagte mir ich müsse die
kapseln von außen mit aromastoffen
versehen
ich sagte nein wir mogeln nicht sie
sehen es war ein globales problem weil
alles fundamental neu war
niemand war vorbereitet 1990 nach vier
jahren erfolglosigkeit mit favre als sie
entlassen er verlässt nest legen
1996 20 jahre nach der erfindung ist der
kapsel café erstmals rentabel verkäufe
übers internet eine hoch automatisierte
produktion und die lancierung als
premiumprodukt helfen beim rasanten
wachstum
es ist ein luxusgut das vom fließband
kommt die kapsel hat auch klienten von
patentanwalt josef färber inspiriert wir
haben eine maschine erfunden die brot
aus der kapsel macht tortilla fladenbrot
außerdem dort bilder maschine die jetzt
natürlich in sich hat aber will der
erfinder habe kommt dass dort wie ein
rausch der menge gas reicht also vor
allem mit den us küsten mexiko natürlich
wurden haar und und dass dieser ruf an
die gmbh stetig wenn es überhaupt nach
muttenz oft oder und das import schwebt
und dänisches für mich dauernd
inspiration für den espace hat dass er
danke momentan könnte bericht
aushändigen teig kapsel und
zwischenlagern und dann automatisch zu
bereiten
es ist herbst 2012 selber zu besuch bei
den tod ihrer maschinen tüftlern ich
gespannt bekomme ich schon vorstellen
doch doch er hat die maschine bislang
nur auf dem papier gesehen
[Musik]
das kann ich so ein richtiger winter
labor und hoffen das funktionieren
natürlich jonas müller und janus friis
haben in diesen keller den prototyp
entwickelt
aber die maschine zeigt sich launig
[Musik]
der lärm verspricht nichts gutes der
konstrukteur nimmt es gelassen
8 fazit passiert aus als trans prozent
vor dem ziel doch mal effektiv
entwickeln sie hier mal dort lagert er
jedes mal aber die 20-prozentige macht
und wo mit den erfolg sieht das
natürlich denn joe cole
einige zeit später ist der fehler
behoben der teig ist in diesen kapseln
verpackt den rest macht die maschine wie
genau das ist streng geheim
[Musik]
beides verändert war harmonie und den
wichtig wir bieten projekt sicher auto
partei will wenn die maschine
funktioniert und günstig die tortilla
suppe spuckt ein riesenpotenzial und
wenn d 3 einer stark verteilt hat der
kann sich keine große firma erlaube das
einfach negieren oder einfach nicht
beachten der demo augen gestreut dass
die erfinder handels einigen anderen
großer konkurrenz schon früher
arbeiteten die erfinder mit
industriedesignern zusammen und testeten
ihre tormaschine in ihrem zielmarkt
kalifornien
dort ist dort ihr das meist gegessene
brot und derzeit so viel mexikanische
rechner das kann ja an diego seinen er
lebt schmeckt
wir denken jetzt der kapsel system ist
ein trend früher war das nicht so der
fall jetzt sieht man überall tipps kommt
dass in amerika kommen auch andere
brands das heißt im richtigen moment
jetzt mit essen gab soll auch so genutzt
sieben monate später so
genau das ist das problem
jonas müller und sein team arbeiten am
nächsten prototypen
er soll an einer nahrungsmittel show in
new york gezeigt werden dass sie relativ
ähnlich aus frose wäre wäre das auto
daten prototyp geräte in der reihe sind
komplett neu zum beispiel warmhaltebox
sehen beim letztlich geradezu risiko und
dass das lösen mit letzterem in der
schublade
und wenn dort erst noch in der maschine
kein warum hatte unsere cloud wird
ausgerechnet aus dem keller erfindern
ist das start-up platte geworden mit
teig und kapsel spezialisten und neu
dabei auch der ehemalige nespresso
manager sebastian kollegen
es ist der innovationsgeist der mich
fasziniert das macht es schon bei
nespresso den status quo wie man brot
macht wie man das macht in frage zu
stellen
es ist er dran etwas zu verändern etwas
zu verbessern
das team hat verschiedene förderpreise
gewonnen
experten geben der maschine gute chancen
erfinder jonas müller ist zum
entwicklungschef aufgestiegen dem
sogenannten cdu das ganz professionell
stellt für mich anfangs einfach mit dem
galaxy s2 schmidtheim innerhalb von zwei
jahren ist aus der idee eine ansehnliche
maschine entstanden gutes teamwork
machte dies möglich ja ich bin stolz auf
die jetzt mit mitgebrachten das ist
schon nicht einfach ziehen und schon
jetzt muss nur noch den super
funktioniert wenn einem semester rechte
vor gericht sind
und so sieht das nokia fladenbrot aus
der maschine made in switzerland aus für
den geplanten markteintritt im nächsten
jahr suchen die erfinder noch einen
starken partner noch dieses jahr rechnen
reinhardt und sein team damit dass sky
live projekt an land zu ziehen
die vertragsverhandlungen sind jedoch
zäh im augenblick sehen parallel für
abendliche mit kasachstan auf der
intercity niveau stetig im jahr 2017 120
notrufe und zum ausdruck vor der vor der
technische aufgaben die kompetenz vor
dem land auf der anderen
mit fortschrittlichem etappen
das ist eine maßstabsgetreue nachbildung
der passagier gondel aus holz
über den sinn dieses projektes lässt
sich streiten
förster sky lift gebaut wird würde
erfinder reinhard damit sicherlich
geschichte schreiben
falls sie denn je gebaut wird es ist so
komplex ist es soweit ich das ich klar
dass er sich nie ins prozent formal
sonderprojekte und von der schweiz und
europa der transport vor der komponenten
ist er wichtig ist auch der geschmack
der umgriff weg nach europa verschifft
passiert
und natürlich doppelt krieg mit ihnen
gesprächspartner sonne im saarland ist
im ganzen tag unterwegs häufig dass der
hof von tesco oder zahlt wird und weil
sie eben immer wieder sagen es darf man
es geschafft die sonne das muss sie
wirklich solides und dass menschen denen
in den kategorien ist schwierig die knie
zwingen
[Musik]
robert miles revolution beim elektro
wählen ist etwas ins stocken geraten
doch stoppen kann ihn das nicht der
erfinder funktioniert einen spieler
durch höhere ersetzt den wie die geld
liegen hatte wieder alles verliert oder
als günther pdf hin die gabe so maier
hofft weiter eines tages entdeckt zu
werden
wie groß die hoffnung dass ich
finanziell bezifferte seifert möchte
nicht dass sie hält er wusste wie le
matin und kann richtig von anfang an
besser entwickeln oder besser schaffen
und so will er sich mit dem minimum was
wir kriegen immer mit der an bremst
gemacht oder kann im fall bin ich gerne
würde wenn ich da viel geld im rücken
hätten wir das nie wie das noch keiner
wusste sicher sein
nein ich meine nein
[Musik]